I stand here tonight and this most holy  of places because mrs. Rosa Parks was  brave enough to set aside her own fears  and take a stand against injustice  [Applause]  today we stood side-by-side in peaceful  protest against the discriminatory  practices of this cities bus rules but  it does not end here  we must continue this journey  [Music]  but there comes a time when  we can no longer bear the weight of the  oppressor upon our backs there comes a  time when we can no longer stand idly by  waiting for the tides of change to pull  us into our freedom that comes a time  when even with the burdening wait of  injustice upon us must gather the  strength to stand and in standing we  will break these chains and we will rise  in the light of our true freedom  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]